meme review last week elon musk
and justin roiland hosted meme review
a legendary episode what do we do now
i don't know we've never gotten this far
how do you follow up an episode like
that you can
you just can't except we will
i have a secret plan in mind for another
bonus move
that's gonna knock it out of the car
just wait
but first it's meme review time
let's freaking do this smash like if
you're excited
when it's steve irvine's birthday and
nobody seems to be celebrating
this is very sad but but
out out of nowhere comes google and
google knows what's up
commemorating the legacy the legend
steve irvin very nice thank you google
very cool but oh no no oh no no we can't
just let things be positive
we can't just have nice things pizza
that's right
pizza everyone decided to take the moral
high ground
and as a response to this google header
peter posted this steve irvin was killed
while harassing a ray
the mental gymnastics of this
organization
he dangled his baby while feeding a
crocodile and wrestled wide animals
who were minding their own business you
know who should be minding your own
business peter
i you you shut up today's google doodle
sends a dangerous voting message
well eddie i can't even read this this
is giving me brain damage
everyone dislike that no one likes you
peta
this is why people don't care about
anything you say
someone replied steve irvin didn't have
a kill rate of 80 percent
you do he didn't donate 70 000 to a
convicted arsonist
you did and he wasn't in bed with
eco-terrorist networks again you
so take your self-righteous bs and
shove it that's right peter now the meme
community
is not happy about this the meme
peter disrespected steve urban on his
birthday everyone
you're like hitler but even hitler cared
about animals or something
he probably did next meme peter
when animal abusers set up dogfights
peter
when chrome changes his logo to honor
steve irvin how could they
hey you're a fairy here to grant your
wishes
i wish i could talk to ponies steve
urban was a hero you [ __ ]
good meme great me there's one way to
properly ridicule and shame
someone is through memes there's no
other way okay shame on you peter
steve urban's memory the whole internet
preaching peter things peter have done
to help animals
wow look nothing when i kill a deer my
parents
family of deer pizza you have to die now
app
elon musk oh god
it's time to go was i a good
organization
no stupid [ __ ]
no one likes you peter just crawl back
into whatever hell hole you came from
okay
no one likes you no one wants you you're
like that one kid in class that
that farts really badly good analogy
felix thank you
irvin hasn't been on a date since losing
steve
i have already had my happily ever have
ah steve urban it's a golden steel tent
[ __ ] you peter next meme elon musk memes
they just kept coming i swear my whole
reddit it's filled with nothing but elon
musk memes at this point
i guess he likes dark humor i guess but
hey man the video didn't get demonetized
so i assume
youtube is fine with it a deer lying
dead in the pool exists
nobody elon musk i love this picture
it's goddamn beautiful pewdiepie with
the sub gap
was literally won and then rose up to
10k
i think it's 100k now thank you very
much
that's the cutest thing i've ever seen
in my life
this has to be one of my new favorite
laughing reaction
it's so good when you tell a slightly
offensive joke
at the dinner table you your brother
the guest the dog hey stop it stop it
with the dolphin jokes
ellen this is not a dolphin you're
drowning oh god he has airpods
of course he has airpods in he's a
billionaire
my god dark sense of humor can be
dementia warning
well then i guess we all have dementia
on this channel let's get real here
oh my god definitely my favorite rick
and morty morning
can't stop laughing thank you justin
boylan for hosting meme review with me
so this was a plan all along i knew it
i freaking knew it teacher why are you
laughing
me nothing my brain elon dusk
what are you laughing at nothing elon
tusk
god damn it teacher what are you
laughing at
me nothing my brain elon musk
teacher what are you laughing at
me ellen did us too
all right jesus christ you know i was
kind of disappointed that elon didn't
like
this meme of himself i was like oh what
a shame
you know i used to think these were
actually funny but then i started seeing
them on myself it's not funny okay it
and i'm saying it genuinely teacher what
are you laughing about
me nothing felix smellberg stop
just stop before it's too late you don't
want to mess with me boy
what are you laughing at huh what are
you laughing at nothing
oh yeah whatever what is this felix
shellberg
this is racism at its finest i mean it's
the worst
what are you laughing about nothing my
brain
felix cajalberg jesus christ
so bad the elon meme
gets a 10. okay the elon deer memes
10 out of 10 baby but the elon teacher
meme
format mm-hmm
what are you gonna do about it cry piss
your pants maybe
next meme another pewdiepie related meme
of course i'm gonna bring this up
evidence shows that vaccines don't cause
autism
anti-vaxx moms what that is that even
supposed to mean
pretty good meme treaty of versailles
exists nazi germany what the is that
even supposed to be
when your girl wants you to touch her
but she's too vague
bombs are vagana
good memes these are great memes these
are fantastic memes
no remains when they see a meme with no
caption
10 out of 10 baby 10 out of 10. my god
damn all right now as a final meme of
this week's
meme review we have a meme that's been
sitting
lurking in the background for quite a
while
and it's kind of taking on many
different shapes and forms
and i don't really know how to summarize
it but i'll try my best to explain this
god-awful
atrocity named ricardo ricardo
started off with tick-tock trolls okay
here i am
basically trying to watch some some tick
tock
videos and then out of nowhere this
freaking
guy comes in and i'm like i'm not gay i
don't like this
it's basically the skedaddle skadoodle
your dick is now one it's basically that
level of
tear okay first you get annoyed but then
it happens again
and and you just look at him and you're
like oh god
him his smile his eyes his dance
his bandana his warmth his existence
and you know i'm not gay but if i had to
pick between a tick-tock girl
or ricardo i'm gonna have to think
really hard about it at least
the eternal struggle between good and
evil
tick-tock girl versus ricardo well
ricardo is stronger
i have to say that he has more muscles
so i think he's got the win on me
okay that's pretty good hey shut up i'm
on skype with someone
sorry beautiful you were saying oh my
heart
oh oh stop it ricardo
we are sitting here in venton and
playing little dota
shut up guys i'm talking to the cute
cutest girl ever
sorry babe you were saying ah kpop
guys no thank you ricardo
[Music]
i don't really understand this meme i'm
gonna be honest why have people spend
hours editing this stuff
i don't know what is this
just stop please well now we understand
where he gets his power from ricardo
meme gets
a zero just because it needs to stop
just stop the ricardo memes please
i'm begging you i think i proved my
point here today because i'm not gay
okay
i don't like men now of course to the
big surprise
who is going to top elon musk and justin
roland
as bonus me who could it be
three two one team review in case you
guys didn't get the memo today is bring
your kids to work day so i brought mine
all right but before i host meme review
i'd like to do a moment of silence for
all our fallen bros in the war on
t-series
[ __ ] what was that did you do it
straight
[Laughter]
just because it's pewdiepie's channel
doesn't mean it's okay
first me so here's the thing pewdiepie
just gave us
a cluster of memes guess we'll just pick
one spending seven million dollars on an
ad
giving pewdiepie seven million i'm sure
they did put this in there
wait giving pewdiepie seven million
little subscribers oh
giving pewdiepie seven million dollars
yeah well i need a few years i'm not
logan paul i don't i don't have that
kind of merch sales
seven's a little high maybe like four
but not seven
maybe like four no you have to give him
his subscriber count give him
his dollar per subscriber no penny per
subscriber cool cool
all right we'll just continue the
admission that i'm filthy rich and move
on
dude this is my favorite four crazy
dudes and what lucky dude
i guess you're the lucky team oh well i
didn't make this name
why whoever made this movie doesn't have
to be yeah they don't have a premium
come on what's going on
from mr beast oh that dude they put some
effort in
the yeah the top right actually are we
allowed to say that
mr b spends hundreds of dollars buying
pewdiepie ads pewds
give bin shapiro's meme review mr beast
am i a joke to you
oh my god you're okay just kidding
i never really wanted to host meme
review because i didn't want to look
like a leech like that's why i only did
all this
but i get barraged by tweets every day
so uh
why not we are yeah one week she loves
me
one week she hates me both weeks i shut
the bed
come on you should get a diaper seems
like the simple fix
yeah dude that's how big jungus came
along he was just sick of shattering the
bed and
so you just gotta i gotta hold it in and
you just blew up
that's like a that's like an eight or
nine for me
we gotta click next mysteries pewdiepie
putting it down
all right that one is pretty accurate up
until you started live streaming it
literally
it's something it's like it do be like
that but seriously it does kind of hurt
when you put
a lot of effort into the board campaign
than pewdiepie the next day or whatever
just like
i don't care if i get past i don't
really care if i'll be a number one and
you're just like ah
but we do we care team review
i am not a racist but
that's how every racist person starts
off everything they say
i'm not a racist but i there's so many
things i want to say i just can't i'm
not as
savage as pewdiepie you know what i'd be
like he would probably say something
slightly racist here
t-series mr beast pewdiepie i mean it's
true
bow down why is pewdiepie so hot what
yeah he's one of the most attractive men
rated yeah
that was a long time ago now he's i was
an attractive elf woman
i don't know i don't really like names
like this my name is terrible and this
is why
i mean it is true ruins the entire media
you didn't have to explain it here
we'll crop it up the good part that's
all we need yeah there it is
this this the meme should just been this
there it is
boom problem solved all right all right
i think we have two left super bowl ad
pewdiepie
knowing this to be supported the most by
spending a lot of money for pewdiepie
saying pewdiepie hundred thousand times
and helping pete if i receive 800 000
subscribers first off i don't think i
ever tweeted that i think you did
no i never tweeted that that is a fake
tweet but anyways let me clear it up a
little bit
basically when i said pewdiepie a
hundred thousand times i said i was
going to try to buy a pewdiepie
the game plan was to sell something
pewdiepie's shirts and hoodies like this
make a few million dollars off of it and
put that towards the ad
that is what i planned on doing and that
is why i said that but
after i uploaded that video we ran into
some complications i learned that
there's a really good chance the super
bowl probably wouldn't approve the ad
like there's some marijuana company that
didn't get approved
even though they offered like ridiculous
amounts of money for their super bowl ad
so then i had a dilemma do i sell stuff
to pewdiepie shirts telling everyone i'm
gonna take all the money and put it
towards the super bowl ad
and then you know make a few million
dollars but then the ad gets declined so
then i'm stuck with a few million
dollars
and then yeah obviously i'd give it to
charity but then people would be even
more disappointed
i didn't know i just i didn't know if
they would reject or approve the ad so i
never went through with the idea
of selling this like really hard with
the promise of buying a super bowl ad so
after that we
decided to make these shirts and the
blankets and get a you know seats right
behind the goal post to promote them
because
we said we were going to do something at
the super bowl and we didn't want to not
deliver anything it's just what we
originally bet and
yeah so this meme doesn't have accurate
information
so it's labeled inaccurate does not get
a rating next
during labor oh god oh man the pain is
so great
that a woman can almost imagine what a
man feels like when he accidentally
kills his dog in minecraft
dude it hurts when your minecraft dog
falls in lava
i may not be able to relate to a lot of
these names but this one hit me right
here dude 12 year old me
oh it hurts i vividly remember my
minecraft dog like falling in lava one
time and i just like
got so sad about it yeah this one's a 9
out of 10. 9 out of 10.
to wrap this meme review up i'd like to
plug something pewdiepie sent me a
message saying i can plug whatever i
want at the end
and i really want to plug grande because
he actually helped us make some of these
billboards he's been a strong fighter
for pewdiepie he's very good for the
meme economy he's really helped with
you know keeping the gdp up you know a
quarter of a quarter and um
i'd like it if you guys want to
subscribe to him so he can make more
memes so pewdiepie could react to him
all right bros that's it for meme review
i'm your general i'm gonna go back to
fighting t-series i appreciate you guys
having me on thank you pewdiepie
honestly if anyone else was the number
one most subscribed to youtuber they'd
probably bring it up a lot or if they
got an argument they'd be like